after i got hurt it was painful to sit
on the sidelines and watch other people
play sports and participate
and
not be involved
when i started this interest in
photography
it was an opportunity to get back into
sports again
my name is lauren worthington and i'm a
photographer
when i was 21 years old i wanted to be a
baseball player i was playing one
evening
and i hit a great double that was a
lousy triple and i slid into third base
came in contact with
the other player's knee
and it pinched my spinal cord the result
of that was paralysis i'm a c56
quadriplegic i've been in the wheelchair
for the past 30 years
it wasn't until almost 20 years after my
injury that i picked up a camera
adapting the camera is kind of an
extension of learning how to deal with a
disability
i cannot use my right fingers
what i figured out is that i could use
an external shutter control with my
mouth
and take the photograph
the type of photography that i do
is about people who are involved in
adaptive sports i felt my best
photographs were of people with
disabilities because
they
saw in me somebody that they could open
up to
when i take photos of athletes i want to
show them as somebody who
works hard who competes hard and who
wants to win
that really shows more about the athlete
than the disability
when i first started shooting adaptive
sports i immediately set my goal to
taking photographs at the paralympics
i got the phone call from the united
states olympic committee that they were
interested in me going to rio de janeiro
in 2016.
there was some of the most amazing
athletes there and it worked out same as
what i've always had to deal with is you
just got to try it probably the first
day it's not going to work so well but
after that you just start getting better
and better at everything you do